thanks for singing guys congratulations
on the film I was like willing you every
step of the way
and like as an audience member to be
that tightly-wound
how was it kind of the you guys actually
having to prepare for it so it because
it seems so intense yeah it was um it
was rigorous it was um it was full-on
but like I think with with the the idea
and the you know the idea in the carpet
of everything about it being so big you
know you can do is take one step at a
time and and we were afforded time and
so we just it was very constant the
whole process and it was lovely you know
just taking it day by day and moving it
layer by layer saver year as well yeah I
mean it was it was tough it was very
physically demanding very emotionally
demanding as well when it required a lot
of you know a lot of focus to be able to
make it and you know very technical it
was a very big technical challenge but
also as actors a challenge to be able to
blend the the two between being very
specific in technical terms but also
being able to just live the scene and be
as natural as you can to be able to be
believable how was it seeing it as well
having gone through it and then seeing
it presented in such way it was amazing
I mean even now I've seen the film I
think about five times now you know and
even though I know everything what
happens in the film it still manages to
get me it's very emotional to watch and
the first time I watched it I picked up
on it before and making the film but
there's almost like a hidden story of
missing home there's a lot of references
back home especially from my character
Blake who's talked about his brother a
lot his mother you know and just
constantly about home and I hit him for
me yeah I found a very emotional
watching it and it's funny I kind of
thought about stuff outside of the film
it made me very clear on on the things
and people that I come back to in in
life and what mean most to me so um yeah
I think you know I hope that people
maybe get a similar kind of feeling when
they watch it yeah and it being based
largely on some answers grandfather were
you kind of it did you know much about
your own kind of family
experience in the wall ordered camo
inspired to go deeper into date
ourselves yeah I am I've read a book
called the Western Front Diaries which
is snippets of diary entries from the
soldiers and I actually found that my
great-great-grandfather David Henry
piers had a diary okay yeah so I would I
would read that you know before stepping
on set a lot and sort of get into that
headspace but not me at me and George
we're not we're not playing Sam's
granddad or anything like that you know
that's how made-up characters but what
gave Sam the idea was was his granddad
telling him you know war stories and
about you George yeah I don't
I only know one relation who fought in
the war which was my great granddad on
my dad's side his mum's dad who was my
dad's Australian and so this his
granddad fought with the Australian Army
at the end of the war he'd only just got
to Australia he'd come across from
Ireland and you know he met he made it
through but I didn't I didn't know that
too recently actually that and there's a
real sense right from the off of
camaraderie between the two of you does
that there was that kind of like a
natural thing as soon as you kind of got
together was it like part of like the
intense training and preparation already
building yeah I think it was a mixture I
mean we just spent so much time together
yeah you know from the gate we met for
the first time on the last audition
which was our third audition for both of
us and then you know we went on research
trips together to France and Belgium and
every single second of the day you know
whether it was learning how to load the
rifle practicing with the weapons you
know military training you know spending
time with Sam and Josh we just had so
much bonding time yeah and and i think
that translated on-screen as well yeah
it's just got me thinking about the
first rehearsal day in November when we
were just walking down the airfield and
Bovington yeah we had a jacket songs it
was cold and we're just talking and just
that thing of like that you know what
conversations but as you get to know
each other that kind of thing and then
and then think of it and here we are now
it's it's nobody has Dean said we've
done everything together yeah I've it
really shows in the film so thank you
very much guys oh thank you thanks you